どうも
昨日まで40度ありましたはじめしゃ
ちょーです
[音楽]
コロナも陰性インフルも陰性
熱中症の症状もなしなんか最近流行ってる
そういうのではなくあの多分普通にその
あの過労です
病み上がりなのでちょっと今日大人しいか
もしれません許してくださいだけど皆さん
掃除してくれるスライムって知ってます
でしょうか普通のスライムってあのただの
公害なんですよ別にスライムを作って
楽しいよ
楽しいんですけどもそれで何かこう日常
生活とか我々の生活に恩恵をもたらすかと
いうと特に何ももたらさないんですけども
世の中にはいいスライムも存在するんです
よそれがこちらお掃除してくれるスライム
ですもう響き的に最高だね1個出して
みようか
はいこれですね
ネットとかで結構人気で売ってるんです
けどもこういうさキーボードの隙間とかっ
て掃除できなくねティッシュハンカチで
吹くこともできない小さい隙間に入り込む
ことができるのがスライムなんです何にで
も使えるでもキーボードとかこの届き
にくい机の隅っことか車のハンドルとか
デジカメとか精密機械もいけるのね
何やってんのこれは何やってんの人形かな
わかんないんですけどノーパサーとか
コントローラーの隙間とかに入ったゴミと
か電卓コピー機とかもうこれだけでわかる
でしょこのスライムめっちゃいいやつなん
ですよ普通のスライムとは全く別でもう
掃除
商品として使われているお掃除をして
くれるスライム買ってみました開けてみ
ましょう
[音楽]
出てきましたこれがお掃除スライムですね
掃除機とかモップとかで届かないところに
手が届くと
伸びるね結構色もめっちゃ綺麗だしなんか
ね
いい匂いがするのよやっぱそういう掃除用
品だから
綺麗にしたといい匂いになるのかなすごい
触って気持ちいいしこれで掃除でき
るっても最高だねちなみにお値段調べてみ
ます
安いこのスライム1匹260円300円
切ってるぐらいの値段ですねちょっと試し
に俺のMacBook掃除してもらおうか
な全然汚れてねえじゃんって思いますけど
こういう隙間のなんかこういうねちょっと
した汚れめっちゃ俺気になっちゃうんです
よねちょっと撮ってみたいと思いますこれ
取れるの本当にうわめっちゃちょっと
シャットダウンしよう
死ぬほど画面動いた大丈夫
壊れないこれ
置いといてもいいってことでしょこうやっ
て結構心配なんだけどパソコンの中入っ
たりしないよねベロンってなるのかな
動かない
完璧な配分だというのかトロトロってし
ないなこれすごいなどろーってなって
パソコンに入ったりすることなさそうです
[音楽]
始まっちゃったどうやって使うんだろう
これ広げておくんかなこうやって広げて
汚れてるところにこうやって置くみたいな
感じなんでしょうかちょっと1個じゃ足り
ないなもう1個追加します足りない時に
たくさん買っといたぜ
また始まっちゃったどうだ
いやもうちょっといるな3つ目
結構でかくなってきたぞこんだけあれば
キーボードぐらい追えるんじゃねさすがに
行けそう
始まった
ちょっと場所的に薄くなったりもします
けど3つぐらいやれば全部覆い隠すことが
できますね
これでビリビリって外すとゴミが
ちっちゃいゴミが取れるよっていう
綺麗になった気がする便利だね
[音楽]
たかがノートパソコンのキーボードでしょ
これで掃除できるのは少ないこれもっと
大きくしてかぶせればもう車ごと綺麗に
なるとかそういうことできるんじゃないか
なと思いまして今回たくさん買いました
[音楽]
買いすぎましたこちらのお掃除してくれる
スライム30万円
迎えました
やったわこれはやりましたと思うただ多分
スライムとは違ってクリーニングお掃除し
てくれるスライムなのでこれねなんか
ちっちゃいのちんたらちんたら
ペタペタペタペタするんじゃなくてバカ
でかいを掃除しないもってベロンすれば
どこでも掃除できるんじゃないかと思って
早速これ全部ひとまとまりにして超巨大お
掃除スライム30万円分作っていきたいと
思います大きさがどれぐらいになるか僕も
わかりませんではまた明日
どうも2日目ですというわけで昨日出した
30万円分のお掃除される全部混ぜて
いこうと思います
[音楽]
できましたこれが30万円分のお掃除をし
てくれるスライムです
[音楽]
これはやばいこれはすごい量だぞやばい
そしてこの結構デカ目の机なんですけど
落ちるあまずいちょっとねー
想像はるかに凌駕する重さですねちゃんと
お掃除スライムくっついてくれるんだ
しっかりくっついてマジでスライムになり
ました今度生地みたい
すごいよ
[音楽]
これだけ大きいスライムがあれば
キーボードとかちっちゃい隙間とかじゃ
なくてこれそのままバコーンっておけば
全部お掃除してくれるんじゃないかそんな
夢のようなお掃除スライムになってます
匂いもなんかその芳香剤みたいな匂いがし
ていい匂いがスライムなのでこいつを使っ
てお掃除してみたいと思いますこれさ何
キロぐらいあるんだろう30万円分のお
掃除スタイルの重さを測ってみたいと思い
ますじゃあ早速重さを測ってみたいと思い
ますもうこれだと体重計乗らないので先に
容器の体重を測りスライムを入れた容器の
重さから容器も引いて体重確認しますまず
容器の重さを測ります3.35kg
容器に最後移しますいくよ
はいはい入るよ
[音楽]
ちょっと待っててくださいね赤信号なので
結構ギリギリだなこれ
[音楽]
測ります
やばい
重くて動かないこれ体積壊れないかな
やばい何キロなんだと思います
引いて65キロ
ほぼ俺だな自分と同じ体重分のお掃除用
スライムが完成してしまいました
いやーすごい量になってしまったなという
わけでこのお掃除さえも使ってどこまでお
掃除できるのかちょっと家で試してみたい
と思いますはいまずは大型テレビ
掃除してみたいと思いますテレビね触ら
ないと思いますが見てくださいここら辺と
か結構埃がたまったりしてますじゃあ
ちょっとテレビ掃除していきたいと思い
ます無限にあるのでねスライムはちょっと
やっていこうと思います
でしょういやマジで余裕すぎる
[音楽]
時もありますよ存分にスライム使っていき
たいと思いますいいねこういう感じで1回
全部覆ってみましょうか
どうでしょうかまこんな感じで良い気がし
ますねちょっと
垂れすぎてるなこれでバーっと取っちゃえ
ば
綺麗になってるはず
[音楽]
汚れてねテレビにスライムついてるんだ
けど
液晶はあんまり良くないのかもしれない
ですねただご覧くださいテレビの上あんな
に汚かったテレビの上がめっちゃ綺麗に
なりましたマジですごいさすが実用的な
スライムだはい次は
配信卓のデスクトップ周り掃除したいと
思いますもうね
キーボードの隙間とか汚れたまってますし
机の上マウスコントローラーもなんか説明
書に装置できますって書いてあったら
カメラとかもあるしもう色んなのまとめて
掃除したいのでスライムぶっかけます全部
掃除になるのでいやマジで便利だなこう
いうことですよね大丈夫大丈夫だよね本当
に俺
デスクトップも言っちゃいますね大丈夫だ
よね結構また俺怖いが勝ってるんですけど
薄く広げて使うのがいいなうわぁこことか
ほこりがすごいもうこういう誇りねこう
いうのねこうやってピターンってやったら
もう全部綺麗にしてくれるっていうね
スライムが乗ったとこと載ってないところ
も差がすごいちょっとどんどん置いていき
たいと思います
[音楽]
いたずらされたみたいになっちゃったこれ
いたずらされてるわけじゃないですからね
マジで掃除中なのでこれちょっとめっちゃ
落ちてきてるこれでこの後全部外すと超
きれいになってるんですよ外していき
ましょう
きれいになったかこれモニターは大丈夫か
何でモニター
くっつくのあこれで取れるんだいやこれ
いいぞこれ結構普通に実用的で楽だそうで
取れば取るほど全部きれいになってると
おおすごいこの下の
キーボードもマウス
も綺麗に
思ったよりなんかその残らないのがすごい
ねスライムが残ったり結構しづらい感じが
しますマジで俺これやばいの作ったから
あーめっちゃ綺麗になったすごいうわ
すごいわかるかなめっちゃ汚れたまってる
んですよこんな素晴らしいお片付け
スライム僕1人で使ってればちょっと
もったいないのでちょっと他の人にも使っ
てあげたいと思います
[音楽]
この下向いてとりあえずはいこれで1回で
何で
管理人の机に来ました結構
じゃないですねここももうスライムで全部
綺麗にしてあげましょうこういう
コンセントとかのタップってホコリが
たまると危ないのでしっかりと綺麗にして
あげたいと思いますパソコンとかこれ多分
立たせといた方がいいんだろうな飲み物は
絶対やばいスライム入って飲んだら死ん
じゃうから飲み物はダメですねスマホも
置いてっちゃって
ますよしじゃあ早速掃除していきましょう
ごめんあごめんじゃねえやいいことしてん
だった
謝ってんだよ
ちょっとやりすぎたかないやでももう
ちょっと感謝の気持ちが強すぎてたくさん
掃除してあげようかなと思う多めに
スライム使わせてもらいましたこれでもう
机のいたるところのほこりが取れスマホは
綺麗パソコンも綺麗もう
完璧なデスクに掃除してあげましたじゃあ
ちょっとターゲット読んでみたいと思い
ます
嫌がらせと思われなければいいんですけど
もレッツ
[音楽]
ゴー
お待たせしましたどうぞはいはい
込めて感謝を込めて
[音楽]
大感謝ですどうぞガラッと開けてください
スライム
おいおいおい待って待って待って待って俺
が大丈夫壊れちゃうじゃん
スマホも置いてっちゃったから
何やってんのえ待ってどこにあるの
安心してくださいお
掃除スライムです
壊れたと思ったマジで終わった
あのーあれだよね
隙間とかに入れてなんかこうゴミッピッ
みたいそうです
けど
全部取っときましたこれそれはあれだけど
さっきあの全部
掃除したばっかりなんですよ
はい外に来ました
掃除お片付けできるもの家の中だけだと
思っていませんか違います皆さん汚れて
いるものは家の外にもあります例えばそう
みんなも乗ったことあるんじゃないかな車
とかも結構ね見てる
見てこれほら見てくださいもうすごい最近
ね雨降ったりするとこういう砂と汚れが
すごいたくさんついちゃうそれよ
スライムスライムこれでちぎってこれを
ここにつけてみますといきますよこれ見て
くださいね
つけます
話しますよ
[音楽]
めっちゃ綺麗ですか皆さんこれがお掃除
すれば力ですこんだけお掃除スライムが
あればきっとこの管理人台中の車も全部
きれいにすることができるはず早速
2番乗せていきましょうやっぱねー車の上
って汚れやすいのよこういうところにこう
やって乗せてあげると
これ多分全然違うよね取ってみていいはい
どうもやばいよこれは嬉しいよね
[音楽]
いやこれ本当に汚れの取り具合すごいん
ですよこことかもう
置くじゃん
めっちゃ綺麗になるんですよいやすごい
すごいこれは絶対喜んでくれるはずです
頑張ります
はいというわけで
[音楽]
管理人大臣の車にスライムあとただのじゃ
ないそれじゃあ嫌がらせになりますお掃除
スライム車に塗りたくりました
車がスライムに食べられているんですけど
も皆さんいなかったじゃないんですただの
スライムじゃないお掃除スライムを構成の
間にも汚れをねこう吸い取って剥がした時
にはもう洗車後みたいな車になってると
思います
足りませんでした足りなくて後ろの方とか
全然濡れてません真横はちょっとスライム
が落ちちゃうんであんまり乗せれなかった
んですけど正面の方は結構しっかり
スライムでお掃除させていただいたので
これはもうカットするでしょう
落ちるんかな
綺麗に仕上がった車を早速ターゲットに
見せていきたいと思いますではさあ
ターゲットはこの変わり果てあ違った綺麗
になった車を見てどう思うのでしょうか
喜んで
[音楽]
ます
ないじゃん
飲み物飲んでいいその
格好
大地君
何でもないです
[音楽]
ねあの
扉ですね
さっき洗車した
めちゃめちゃあれなんか
汚れてて
じゃあ喜ぶかも
[音楽]
よ
さ
スライムで洗車しときました
[音楽]
マジでスライム取ったらほら
めっちゃ汚れ落ちるんだよ
最近交差でさすごい茶色くなってたから
全然やってよ
[音楽]
僕こっち乗ります
[拍手]
[音楽]
綺麗失礼します
落ちそうになるんだけど
失礼します
[笑い]
水族館みたいだねうまいこと言うなよ
お願いします行きます
[音楽]
動かなくなっちゃった
じゃあ
これで帰っていただいて
ここから見るんか
[音楽]